Hey Dr. Bucket, you could please introduce yourself with your name and today's state
in our location. My name is John Block, today's date is August 5th, 2014, and we are in
the family room of my house. And we're going to talk a bit about your career in pharmacy
and your association with OSU and want to start off at the beginning of your board in
the Acomo Washington. That is correct. Is that where you're erased?
Yes, all the way through high school and then Washington State University for bachelor's
degrees and master's and University of Wisconsin and Madison for my doctorate.
What were your parents' backgrounds?
You mean, business wise, education wise, what does it give us a sense of, okay, well my mother
was born and raised in the Accommonics. It's a funny story. Her parents were, and probably
the last group of pioneers, they're actually listed in the Acomo Valley Historical Museum
on some wall plaque with, they actually came out in a pioneer train. They were on a wagon train.
But so she was raised there and born on a farm. I think my granddad was a foreman or something
like that. It was not his farm. And the interesting thing was, her birth was never registered
because she was a girl baby born out on a farm. And I was not pertinent later on after she was married
to my dad who I mentioned just a moment. They got a court order. So her is the court order
of birth certificate, which then paid off when Medicare came along because she could prove her age.
My dad was raised in Buffalo, New York. And in those days, there was no state university in New
York per se. They were the state of New York supported different majors at private schools.
So I think forestry was at Syracuse, engineering was at Cornell, things like that. And he was
a twin and second born. There he had an older brother and his dad being German.
Said the oldest son was the one who's going to get to go to college. So my dad took commercial
courses and a senior here in high school, his dad, my granddad told him whether there was
enough money for him to go to college. Well, my dad sort of said he didn't take the college trip
courses. So he was not eligible for any New York school. So he went to the University of Pennsylvania
graduated from the Warden School of Business Administration as my dad said before Harvard stole the
faculty, hired onto the firestone tire and rubber company. And Harvey Firestone Jr. was in his training
class. And then as he looked for a position to be a firestone tire salesman, he found that the
Eastern and Washington are actually central Washington District had done very poorly. And he had
been advised, don't replace every tire in salesman who is real successful because you will go down,
go to one that is not successful, and you can go up. And he was successful. And he basically,
I think was headquartered in Yakima, but his territory took him all through Eastern Washington.
And they small-beat towns, close to Washington. I guess over the coal facts,
maybe up to Spokane that I'm not sure. Met my mother or I guess they were going to a baseball game
somewhere and got married. Draw a model A Ford for their wedding trip back to Buffalo,
which is where he was then going to work. He resigned from Firestone. And as they've gone,
I guess into Canada, crossing Detroit Windsor, then into Canada, then across the peace bridge
into Buffalo. And the immigration customs guide on the U.S. side, of course, asked who they were,
where they were born. My dad said he was born in Buffalo flying. My mother was very naive
and said she was born in Yakima. He left after what part of Japan was that? And she didn't have
a birth certificate as I indicated. Well, then the so-called Chicago, and obviously,
depression struck. And what people didn't realize was that depression was roughest in the
industrial parts of the United States, because the manufacturing stopped. The people were all laid off.
In the rural areas, things weren't great, but people ate and they bartered. So my dad decided
we're going to head back out to the state of Washington. And he had business contacts who could
help him get established. And so that's how he got back west, left Buffalo, and got going
in Yakima on a basic bill of independent fuel, gasoline, distribution, business, fuel oil before
natural gas had come in. Did you have any siblings? I had my brother died a couple of years ago.
He was eight years older than me. And I say nine, a couple of years ago. He graduated from Washington
State also, ROTC, back in the days of the Korean War. And there was a draft on.
And state in the military got to be a bird kernel. And so actually, I attended and participate
in his internment in Arlington with the full case on band, the whole ceremony.
What were you just screwing up as a boy in Yakima? Well, that's interesting. I guess I
dabble around photography. I had a dark room. And would shoot pictures. I had a 30-fold
Argusy 335 millimeter camera. I graduated from a brownie, Kodak Brownie. And we'd
develop my pictures. I never did do color, did family photo Christmas cards. Took some of the
pictures around the church I grew up in. And I got on the stage crew. Those days was Yakima,
senior high school is only high school down those days. And it was also the city Kodakarium.
That would be a nice Kodakarium, full stage dressing rooms in the basement. And we would be
those stage crew if we worked for a somebody putting a show on, we would get paid. So I got
fine at a response position. I even got a key to the stage area and learn how to get along
with the janitors. So I was on the stage crew when the Air Force band came through and it was
a stage circus with a little baby elephant in the basement that upset the janitor because he made a mess.
And of course there were the plays and things like that that were put on.
How much year early is it interested in science or in pharmacy? I guess it was just the science
courses that we had to take curriculum in those days was pretty regimented and in high school.
And well even I come out of the air of Junior High. So grade school went through sixth grade.
Junior High was 7th through ninth and high school is 10th, 11th and 12th grades.
And had had very good science teachers. They all had master's degrees pretty much in their
science and their subject matters opposed to a master's of teaching. And I guess that was
how I got my interest. I didn't pick pharmacy right away. I went as an undeclared major at
Washington State and hunted around and went to the counseling center and sort of looked at
that and I thought we like you kind of I kind of had the pre-farmacy curriculum of what I was doing.
And it was one where I didn't think I'd be stuck in a lab. I would know the public well I had
up in a lab anyway after grad school and academia. Well tell me about your experience at Washington
State's undergrad in the budding pharmacist. Well we lived in there were two political parties in
those days. There were the Greeks and the independence. And there was none of this that
freshmen lived in the dorms their first year. If you pledged you went to your Greek house immediately.
The person who was in charge of the dorms believed in a strong dorm system and loyalty and so forth.
So if you went Greek by God you went to your fraternity or sorority for the women. And of course
there was no such thing as co-ed dorms. The boys were on one side of the campus and the girls
on the other side of the campus and if you didn't get the girl in on certain times you got a campus
and you had to give her a dozen roses which happened to me once. And the dorm I was in was nice.
They were sweets of rooms. They had wash basins in the rooms. There weren't the long hallways.
It was I won't call a semi-private but they were nice and they were quiet. That real thick walls
between the rooms so plaster on lathe. So it was good and we had a good reputation. We got one of the
higher grade point averages. There was this type of competition and in a mural which I didn't
participate and I was my worst sport school was PE. And just as an aside you'll never guess who my
highest one of my two high school physical education structures were a whole break before he went
off to Washington State to be the famous baseball coach he was a high school PE teacher.
What was the curriculum like for you in pharmacy as an undergrad? I've seen it was somewhat
different from what students did. Yeah it was well we had compounding and it had a lot more lab
involved. And so I said we would compound at appointments and creams and suspensions and elixirs
and all that type of stuff. Otherwise medicinal chemistry with medicinal chemistry based on what
was known those days. Pharmacology was pharmacology. Pharmacology was pharmaceuticals. It just there
wasn't as much known. The concept of receptor was just that receptor and it never been one
and it never been isolated. Drug design was in its infancy which is basically a group of compounds
and just the companies would screen them and if they got hit they got hit. They got hit.
The keyfob are amendments have not yet passed so you have to tell in a mind situation occurred.
I'm trying to remember when the efficacy requirements went in and they screened all the
over the counter drugs and reform laid a lot of them because the brands were popular but they had to
take ingredients out because they couldn't prove they were effective. So I would say the science and
the efficacy requirements have greatly increased over the years and now they're of course into
all the reevaluating the type of statistics that are used and how much are the companies
and I don't mean this an anti company thing at all because I'm sure some of the same stuff went
on the lab and then university labs too. I'll just look at the number of papers that are
mean retracted nowadays coming out of university labs and institutes and so forth.
But when you throw out a bad study when we're out of the bad study it was probably a very important
study that said something you better be alert to. So I would say there's a lot more
in this day and age of electronic communication and so forth. Many, many ways the public may be
better protected. By the time that you'd finish your wash since day it was pretty clear you're
going to be a pharmacist it seems. What about it? I feel the you what was here. It sparked your interest
those in pursuing career in pharmacy. Well I knew I could not do medicine because you know some
only my hands here and there's a slight tremor. I have what's called familial or idiopathic
tremor and hair different grandmother through mother through me and at least in medical school
on those days there was a required surgical rotation and you would not want me to be your surgeon.
In fact in physiology we had to do surgeries on rabbits and we all had to take turns and I didn't
do too well in my rabbit. Unfortunately I had three other people on the team that could bail me out but
I was one of those kids in grade school when testing amazement came along first grade.
I couldn't get my bow tied on my shoe. I really clets it my hands.
So you didn't want me in medicine at a hall or dentistry or anything like that.
But I can count or lick and stick. I mean which of course and convey knowledge to the
customer or the client. But the follow-up later became Dean at Washington State
looked at my record and said basically I think you ought to consider graduate school.
So that's just a faculty member took an interest.
So you had to put me off in that direction. You had an interest or it's definitely. Definitely.
We went to Wisconsin briefly after Washington State.
I was there for four years. Right with you. Did you do some post-grad work in it?
Wisconsin right after you finished your bachelor's degree?
I write about that. After I'm in a bachelor's degree and I stayed at Washington State
to get my master's. And then went to Wisconsin. I was there for four years and a typical period
time to get a doctor at least in the chemical like pharmacy sciences came here.
So I graduated basically in 1966. Tell me about your graduate training at Washington State names,
Wisconsin. Washington State was a traditional, I mean for the master's was a traditional
medicinal chemistry. I had a research problem. Make a series of compounds.
And I wasn't there if I wanted to be tested. But that was basically it. And of course you take
the appropriate chemistry courses with it. In fact most of the courses were in chemistry except
for an advanced course in drug design. I was in Wisconsin. Did you want me to jump to Wisconsin?
Yeah, one of you ready. Okay. I was concerned again there. They didn't have a court.
It was interesting. I was originally going to work for a different chemist. And he moved on to Kansas.
And I said I ended up in Wisconsin. And that's interesting story. Okay.
God, we'll be able to have a lot of inches on here. I guess it's no longer inches on a table. It's a
silica chip. I applied to three different graduate schools. All right. I wrote to three different
graduate schools and applied to two, if I remember. I told you the person I was interested in
it. Wisconsin had moved to Kansas at Lawrence. But they sent me old-out-bated catalogs.
So I just shook it off. I had, there were a couple new faculty members at Washington State who
were both Wisconsin grads. So I was sort of getting input from them at the same time. And they knew
the, the personalities at Wisconsin. I applied to the University of California San Francisco,
which is where the pharmacy. That's the medical center, the University of California. The original
medical center for the University of California system. They're more than one now. And applied
there and was accepted with a teaching assistantship. I got accepted at the University of Wisconsin
with a research assistantship. And they, these two, fell of faculty and faculty, system professors,
as grab the research assistantship and you can start right out in your research speed things along.
So I did. And it was very interesting. In late spring, I got a letter from the University of
California San Francisco saying they would award me a Smith client of French fellowship.
I think probably I was a runner-up and whoever they originally gave it to,
turned it down and went somewhere else. But by that time I had made my choice and it didn't seem
right to back down. And it would have actually been unethical for California to accept
of me then. I don't think they would have cared. But it turned out well. I got my doctor.
I met my wife, this December, would be our 50th wedding anniversary. So it worked out well.
It was constant. Tell me about the environment there. How was it? It was different from what
Washington State. Oh, Wisconsin was definitely a research university. It was definitely a publisher
parish for the faculty. The undergrad, as the former dean told me on my exit interview,
he said, you want to understand the role the undergraduate. They provide the tuition
and support so that you faculty can do your research. So treat them nicely.
I mean, there was that no-if I answered lots about it. You got to keep in mind,
Wisconsin had a longer tradition than a lot of the big-tem schools,
because they had the Wisconsin Alumni Research Foundation. So when you drink your glass of milk
with vitamin D and the royalists from that patent have gone to the University of Wisconsin,
if you are using warfront as an anticoagant for a rat poison,
the warfest Wisconsin Alumni Research Foundation. That was all discovered at Wisconsin
and ought to go so they were in the business full-time, make no mistake about it.
And a lot of us sort of had a reaction too, like, do we want to be a system of
professors in this type of environment? So when the opportunity came to come to Oregon State,
it seemed nice attractive because there was more emphasis on the teaching.
Well, before we go, I see I'm interested in a little bit more in your research as a graduate student
and how I progressed. Well, I went well. I got publications. It was a different type of
problem. It was not a drug design problem. My major professor was actually in the natural
products, and he was very successful at it. He, but he had what was called a physical organic
problem. He made his claim to fame by actually, I think, finding an error in a structure that
the late RB Woodward had developed. It was just the only error was in the stereo chemistry. But anyway,
so he wanted to follow up on that. And so basically that was my problem. So I did not have to do
the natural products isolate and hope I got everything done with the 10 milligrams. I could get how the
plant. I could just keep making my com. My simple little compound and keep running tests on him so
it was that type of problem. And but otherwise it was a standard graduate university graduate
chemistry lab. Plant benches, everybody in their working postdocs and graduate students.
We came to see a 1966 and it's only a bit about the decision to move back to ordering.
It was mainly jobs were kind of tight academic jobs. I had a chance to interview at the
chemical abstract service. That's the American chemical site is the parent of it in Columbus, Ohio.
And I could tell that was all going to get computerized at some point. I thought that would be a
good mix. And I think I would have done well. But this other position came along and
I talked to the major professor and decided to take it. So it turned out
that there was an opening also at the University of Nebraska, which I guess I really wasn't
that aware of. But a person I later knew and he and I became co-authors on the first textbook I
was involved with. And he said, oh, yeah, he knew about the, I'm not sure where he got his PhD.
But he knew about the Oregon position and later heard it was got filled in realize it was me
until later we met with comparing notes. And I glad it took Oregon because things have not gone
well for pharmacy in Nebraska. They were in Lincoln and they got moved to the medical center in Omaha,
and the provost of mood done was all very pro. Then it was then the Nebraska start half financial
problems. There were two pharmacy schools in Omaha and the governor said, you know, I need one,
why do we let Crayton be it? I don't know what he was so against having one of the state school,
but anyway. So they had budgets cut. They did say the school, but
when budget cuts like that happen and faculty, good faculty aren't going to go there and some leave,
that would not have been a good situation. This has been a growth situation and the pharmacist
goal here has grown professionally and enrolled in two of the professionally. What were your
initial impressions of the University of Corralis? Well, Corralis was a nice beautiful college town,
even. I should say even in those days of this. And I like the fact I could even bicycle from Wisconsin.
The interview was weird. I have to say because my colleagues at Madison were going for their various
interviews or talking about these research presentations they had to give and all this and I come
out here and there was no affirmative action. None of that type of stuff. I was hired in the back
seat of the Dean's car in the townhouse, Motel, after 24 hours of interview. So anyway, things were
like this. So I had a job and my wife was very flexible and she had gone to school out of state
so forth as far as her batches and traveled quite a bit. So she was fine. She's enjoyed this town too,
very, very much. So climate-wise it's superior to the winners of Wisconsin and then you have the hot
muggy summers with the mosquitoes and Wisconsin. So now this is a very pleasant place to live.
How do you characterize the department upon your arrival? Very heavy, teach and orientate,
orientate and very, very structured. It was a small faculty. It was no date I believe. It was a
school of pharmacy and then I think under President McVickard, it got to be Oregon State University
was not Oregon State College. My god, it was Oregon State University and some of the
academic units were colleges and some were still schools and he finally said, look, if I guess he told
the Dean's, I guess, I mean, I wasn't, that if you want to be a college, you can be a college. So
I guess we changed our letterhead. We became a college and that meant we had departments.
But there weren't that, I mean, medicinal chemistry had a department head and two faculty.
Pharmacidics had a department head and three faculty. Pharmacology had a department head and two
faculty. I mean, it was crazy and I think there was a department of pharmacologists,
which is the old term for natural products and I think they had two faculty. So the Dean didn't
have faculty meetings, this was Charlie Wilson. He had department head meetings and so these four
sort of senior colleagues sort of ran the school and the rest of his sort of picked up by
osmosis, what the heck was going on. There we have faculty meetings once in a while.
So was there any sense of the history of the program that had been around since 1898?
No, and in your research, you, whatever you can find and I don't mean this negatively, but
there was a former Dean, name was Klossam and he committed suicide and I actually had a graduate student
who was an undergraduate here at the time that occurred. I don't to this day know exactly what the
situation. I obviously had depression of some type and there was some story that he
had run up gambling debts and so forth, but I honestly don't know the truth.
To his credit, he was a Minnesota grad as I understand it and he brought one of the first
Rokai Rokai's the National Pharmacy Honor Society, Tory and State, I remember what chapter we are,
but we're one of the very early chapters, is it a fight out tonight? No, no, fight out of the
guy is a pharmacy fraternity, a co-ed. There's no them co-capicide that I was a member of.
No, no, Rokai Rx. And there used to be a women's sorority, I think it's fallen by the
wayside, well I know it has an Oregon State and there were a faculty who were fight out of the
guy who wanted, that's why basically fight out of the guy, used to be both fight out of the
guy in capicide, capicide fell by the wayside and fight out of the guy is been the predominant
and I haven't sure how active it is anymore, but Rokai still initiates top students each year.
There is also a leadership group which is fairly new, and I don't know what it is and I
get, I think it Rokai do a joint induction ceremony to spring a Los Alster word or CH2MHL
Center somewhere like that. So, after Closen died, they brought in Charlie Wilson who had been
at Minnesota and was down at Texas and he was co-author of a very famous well-established, became
very well-established, medicinal chemistry, textbook, it was Wilson and Gisold and only Gisold was also
at Minnesota, they started at Minnesota and it was the first. So when I had as an undergraduate even
and the later it got to be multi-authored, I ended up being a co-editor for a couple of years
of an author of a chapter two for one or two additions. Anyway he came and his idea, he was told
he was supposed to try to start increasing the research capability. So he was hiring young
faculty at a graduate school, there was a new pharmaceutical person, it was a pharmacologist,
got a good grant fairly early. I never was able to get anything big. I would get smaller grants.
And the pharmaceutical experts went off the industry and it was a didn't own house.
There was an addition to the building made. That was just going on. When I interviewed,
they were in the finishing state, I came in December for that was the Christmas break.
And in fact, you know how you usually paid it, bring a person out for interview.
No, I took my wife to Yakimo for the first time at Christmas time. After Christmas, we drove down
to took my mother's car and drove down to Corvallis, went through the interview.
I think I might have got reimbursed from my lease later. He did pay first,
staying in a motel on the way back because there have been quite a bit of snow. So,
got me cheap as far as there was no this hiring startup money, start up your lab,
all this time. But to answer the question, when I came, the faculty had
were scared around campus because of the addition. So, when I arrived in September,
they were all back in the new building. And the labs were set up. And I see that it was pretty impactful,
in these ways. Potentially, yes, it did start some research going and they started to see some
increase in graduate students. All of those were speaking to Department of Pharmacy Administration
with maybe one other faculty member at the New Harvard ad, I'm not sure if I made it over to.
There's interesting story that goes, Charlie Wilson worked very hard to get that addition put on.
And he got approval, I guess, eight, but those days, it definitely had to go through a
legislature. And the new offices are all to be labs with few hoods and the faucets and the gas outlets,
and so on. He went to NIH, money was a lot more plentiful from the federal government of those days.
He went to, and I think it was NIH, makes sense. And got a grant to outfit these offices as labs.
An unbelievable, the state said, we've budgeted X amount of money. Since you got this federal money,
we're going to subtract the state money. And so, he sat down the plans and put X's through
marking out which lab labs and which ones would not have few hoods. Did you get one that had a lab?
I had one that had a hood because I was a new young assistant professor. But that's how strange things were
in Oregon, for example. Which department were you in? Either we were called medicinal chemistry
or pharmaceutical chemistry, I forgot which. At the industrial level the term pharmaceutical
chemistry is what's in the academic level. We might call pharmaceutical. It's just formulation.
And the drug design is in medicinal chemistry. But in academia, it's seen like pharmaceutical
chemistry with the drug design area. So what were your responsibilities in this initial position?
Well, I was surprised. I was going to be teaching a lab in medicinal chemistry. I didn't think there
was such a thing left. So I taught a lab in medicinal chemistry. Which took a lot of time.
Was this what you need by such a thing that was left? Is this sort of an older approach?
Yeah, yes. Oh yeah, they did very side-billed. I honestly gosh cannot remember
where these experiments came from and so forth. But we slow it took years to get rid of that lab.
We I did not teach in the farm. We had a pharmaceutical analysis course and there was a lab in that.
And those labs slowly disappeared as more didactic material got into the course.
I ended it starting the second year. I taught the biochemistry course because that was my
minor at Wisconsin. And the story on that is very, very interesting. I see a smile so
maybe you know part of the story. The dean and one of the other senior faculty had
daughters, I think both daughters, who were in pharmacy and were really
complain about the quality of instruction from the Department of Biochemistry.
It used to be biochemistry and bio physics. And one of the complaints was that each quarter
they would keep changing instructors and this would happen each year. So over in the pharmacy
school you couldn't get a reading on what was being covered when the students coming in who had
had the biochemistry course because there was this rotation of instructors going on. It was a service
course. And the pharmacy students would start to complain when they're kind of a cohesive bunch.
And that made the biochemistry faculty angry. And finally the dean says I'm going to yank the course.
Start teaching at John and try to make it unique. Well they had a rule in those days.
There was to be no duplication of course work on campus. And they really got a tight about it.
But I did and I started with a course towards a clinical approach and a nutrition approach.
So I started to change a lot of stuff in the biochemistry. Still went through intermediary
metabolism. We still went through protein chemistry. No labs though. Chemistry carbohydrates.
And then what was known about DNA and RNA? And of course that is mushroomed. But I picked up and
started to cover diabetes. The biochemistry or diabetes. The biochemistry of hyperlipidemia is
before there was much known about hyperlipidemia. I think everything was cholesterol in those days.
And so on. And then I wrote a paper for the American Journal of Pharmaceutical Education
on a clinical approach to teaching a biochemistry. Most successful paper ever wrote all my
100 reprints disappeared. They all got requested. I gave an oral presentation at the American
Association called to the pharmacy. And it was packed. I was on a rule. It was not what you call research.
Well, the chair of biochemistry and other faculty member came over to have a meeting and said
do we teach that? Well, I didn't teach that approach. And they find it up and we just want you
know that we teach it too. But you go ahead and teach your stuff. Okay. I got along actually with
most of them over there. Fine. We got along. But every so often it would come up one of the
faculty members over Dixon in the dressing room and it came up. His faculty members in pharmacy
and this other this fellow in biochemistry says, so how come it is you keep teaching that biochemistry
course. There was a physical chemist in our living room. I wife was very active with American
field service AFS and there was a group in our living room and the physical organic chemist said,
all of a sudden, you know, you really have no business teaching biochemistry. It wasn't even
a department. You know, that's really solar along the line. I had a different reputation,
different parts of the canvas I guess. It's kind of fun. But I can once you get tenure what they're
going to do, you know. But eventually when we went to the doctor pharmacy program
we met with the Chris Matthews chair of biochemistry and basically they took the course back and it was a
higher level course that we had to student send rather than the service course. I told him what I was
going to continue teaching, which was the nutritional aspects and some of the diseases and
they said fine can aim our students. Come on, I said sure. I don't think I ain't never did. But
so everything was fine. My understanding now what they have done is they're only requiring the first
two years first to some quarters of biochemistry because we're still on the quarter system.
And I'm not sure how they're handling the molecular biology. It has changed so much and
with the heavy research emphasis, the faculty are extremely focused doing their teaching.
So you and you get such a turnover of faculty going on in the biochemistry and that's our courses too.
There's a very rare where you'll see one faculty member sees a course from again and they'll
be a course coordinator. Could basically the job is to make sure the grades get submitted on time
to the registrar. So there's a lot of this. You might say it's a medical school model. It's going on.
Did it seem that pharmacy was resistant to change in terms of the curriculum early on or
no, in fact, just the opposite weeks, you like what always had curricular upheavals.
And that was going on nationally too. There are these trends that you got to change the
clinical pharmacy. You got to do this, you got to do that, you got to put in communication skills,
you got to put in cultural sensitivities. Yeah. Oh no, no, no. There's
it was always in state of flux. Always going through transitions. And what do you do about a student who
was not right in sequence and the curriculum changed? What do you do for them? No, no, no.
That's just the opposite. We're very fluid. Tell me about setting up your research. It was you.
That got off to a slow start. I basically had some undergraduates and I really had trouble
getting going. I did one based on my Ph.D. and got the paper published.
But I was always fascinated in what's called quantitative structure activity relationships.
And it's a statistical method of drug design. And I end up with a graduate student named Doug Henry,
who was very good at statistics. And that's basically what Doug is where I got the bulk of my
papers. I had a couple of the graduate students and got papers. But overall, I basically got into
the drug design area and was published in that area and it would go off to the Gordon Research
conferences. It started to get a little bit of money from the Army. It was not the chemical warfare
bunch that type. And go back to their research conferences and did certain things with them.
I mean, published and nothing was classified. And I made a contact at a Gordon conference.
So let's say it was that. So that's the best way I did. I don't have that many papers.
And I'd never really got any real big grants. I think the biggest ever goes 10 or 12,000.
Was the model pharmacy? The model drug store still around?
Oh, when I came, well, that there was a prescription lab. And they had cubicle. So the students learned
a dispense. And there was phones. And there's some faculty member or a graduate student
to a function as a doctorate fine in prescriptions. So there was still that. Yes, but that's disappeared.
What was your sense of the climate on campus when you arrived in the sixties preceded in
sort of well, when I bicycle onto the campus that late September, first day of classes,
there was a group of freshmen and green beanies. And I was dumbfounded. I could not believe this.
Because I've been to Washington State. It was not such thing as green. I mean, it was just a regular university.
I could not believe it. It was a cow college. It was an ex-school.
When I saw the PhD curriculum, it was loaded with coursework. And the story goes.
And I want to emphasize story because I never heard it face to face. But the dean of the graduate
school on those days believed in lots of coursework because he knew that Oregon State PhD graduates
were not going to go to the big research universities. They were going to go to the smaller schools
and be teachers. So they need to take a lot of coursework so they could teach a number of subjects.
Oh, that's interesting. When, obviously, I knew I wanted to get canured. And in my third year,
I got a letter from the President of the University Dr. Jensen saying, you have canured.
I like this. I like this place. Okay. I wasn't promoted yet, but I had tenure after three years.
Oh, no. Okay. Then he retires and goes off with the Rockefeller Foundation somewhere.
And they bring in President McVicker, Robert McVicker, who was a one-man show. There's no question
about it. A one-man show. Turned out he was a member of our church. And so at our annual church
picnic, he was there with his wife. And there was a, oh, a shoot faculty member who was taken around
and introduced. And so I got introduced to him. Well, it turned out that I had learned ahead of time
that yes, he was a graduate at the University of Wisconsin. His PhD's in Biochemistry.
And a person who I actually taught my major professors course to the undergraduate at the
Wisconsin. And there was an individual, it was on sabbatical from industry, a man named A Perlman,
who was just a gentleman. And he gave the bottom of lectures in this course.
And somewhere along line, A Perlman told me, oh, Mac, there's my professor was called,
and I, we're graduate students in the same lab in Madison. Say a little to him.
And then Perlman, we later became dean at Wisconsin. So here I am at medium president of the
vicar. And I said, yeah, I know a day of Perlman. Oh, and he's now keeping, he's both dean
and maintain his research program. And Mac's comment was, well, it's only dean of a pharmacy school.
I went back into old dean of Wilson. I said, you got a problem. You got a big problem.
He didn't have a problem that turns out. I mean, he went on business retirement so forth.
No matter, everything is said, I've never heard of Mac fire anybody without due cause, but what happened
getting on back to my own personal. I went up for promotion and it was turned down.
This is happening all over campus because he wanted a standard dossier where you use outside
referees. Well, it threw my department and he didn't know what to do. But to Wilson's credit,
Dean Wilson's credit, who had been at Minnesota and at Texas, he knew exactly where Mac was coming
from and what had to be done. He said, okay, here is what we are going to do. We got the outline.
I need outside referees. And so I may have professors at school's function and for him.
And then I got, I did get promote the next time around and then made it to professor on the first
time around on that. So, but that was happening all over campus and not only were young faculty
in shell shock, but you had department heads who had never been turned down. All they did was
try to let her say they wanted it. So, and so promoted, continued and it was done. You had Dean
who had never been turned down and it was, you look back on your lap, but oh yeah, it was a traumatic
time. There was no question about it. But the result was Oregon State University today.
And what I never have understood is why there's no building or anything like that named after him.
There are young faculty, I have no idea who he, who Mac was. And you give them a lot of credit
for repelling University for it. Oh, I would say he, without him, we would still be second
fiddle to the University of Oregon. And I mean, real second fiddle. I think promised they could be
ahead of us. No, he knew what had to be done and he pushed. And that's, he is, as one
person that he was his own provost, we had to be in a faculty in those days. They didn't think
of Dean was who was kind of the good cop. The Mac was the bad cop as the president of
the university. But I know, I know, I know, I know, and he had it quite a temper, but he could flare.
But I, I don't know if anybody who is out out fired, who locked horns with him, he just let fly
and, uh, but I, I just, I don't know if anybody who was, and I'm not saying there wasn't,
but he really followed protocol when we did not grant tenure to a faculty member. Boy, he wanted
to make sure everything was dotted and he reviewed it carefully. I think one thing I did when he
lost it was obviously, but I think he, I think basically, if you were right about this fellow
who was a president for a long time at Boston, I want to say Boston, he did at Boston College
of Boston University, Silverman, John Silverman, and there's a review in the Wall Street Journal
of a book he had written. Well, he's dead not so much when a couple of your few years ago.
But he, he brought the school, that school, up into a major research university in higher
top notch faculty. And he believed in academic freedom, but he also wanted to bleed in excellence.
And, uh, it caused the real transformation. And I kind of look at the, the two people,
Mach never wrote a book, as far as I know, uh, as the two of the same type, they had this goal,
and they know it could be done. And if I get the right faculty, I know it could be done.
And he basically did. What does he remember about him as a person?
And it sounds like you knew him a little bit when I kind of a first and a little.
He was very distant.
And I say we're in the same church, and he just never seemed to let his guard down to
after he retired. He just lived over here a couple of blocks away.
And one day after he retired,
uh,
I don't know if he's here with a petition for us to sign or what, but he showed up to the house,
come on in, sat down on the couch out there,
and just talked. He even talked about being hired and things, he'd just,
everything was fine. He was retired now. There was no, there was no barrier between us.
There was a neighborhood dessert from our church, and we got the thing mixed up on the counter.
So we, why I'm not push the tour bell. And he said, well, we're here for the dessert.
Well, that was last night, his life's going to be as a boat, guys. He says, come on in.
I think we have some pie, we have some cake, and his wife is always very gracious.
And we sat down and visited for a while.
Well, said, one of the colleagues of yours were important to you. It OSU,
other within pharmacy or elsewhere. Well, that was at the Department of Head, Bob Dorgie,
who was very good. One that we were basically parallel to each other was George Constantin.
Who's here? I mean, he's over Albany, but he's not alone. You could always interview.
Let's see. As far as contemporaries, I would say, those two, for the most part.
In doing some research on pharmacy, it's sort of more recent here,
is that a couple of names that have stood out as people who have made an impact on me.
Oh, I'm sorry. I'm going to speak one more.
The dean, who, the gentleman who replaced Charlie Wilson and Stico, who was there for a long time.
Yes. And he once, he said, John, how would you like to be on the board of pharmacy?
And I thought, okay, that sounds like an intriguing deal, because I wasn't setting a world
on fire, research wise, and this is a state board of pharmacy. Yes, a state board of pharmacy.
So I think I put my name in and the old guard and the profession that we're not going to have
I think I remember on the board of pharmacy. It's ridiculous. And the bank can take him up again.
He says, let's make another run at it. And I don't know what I have behind the scenes, but I got
a point at the board of pharmacy. The old goldsmith. Now he didn't know me from out of
it's all done by the appointments office. And they, of course, checked politics. The board of pharmacy
was sure it was not on the goldsmith's political radar screen. So I got on the board and it was
a executive director on the board, Ruth Banderbeer, who had a real vision where pharmacy could go.
She had basically been the author of the revised pharmacy practice act, which gave
pharmacists a lot more responsibility in the state. And I started to go to National Association
of the Board's Affirmacy and Regional Meetings, ended up offering a couple resolutions.
Got on to task force of the board, ended up being on one of the permanent committees of the
National Association Board of Pharmacy and one of the exam committees for foreign pharmacy graduates.
So that, I would say, Dick had a real impact. I was on the board for the mandatory eight years.
When I say a mandatory, you can't exceed eight years. And was president of the board twice.
I was asking about a couple of fellows from the pharmacy department or the school pharmacy,
but it sounded like it made it an impact through their research and one of them is James Ayers.
Oh, yes, yes. He was on sabbatical somewhere and I got a call from Professor Sandeen,
a microbiology. And I want to say it's Bill Sandeen, but I may have the first name wrong,
but anyway Sandeen. And he wanted some way to develop some method of buffering
bacterial cultures in the cheese making process. And I said, well, in the formulation person is
Jim Ayers. And so Jim comes back and they meet each other and they kept quite a collaboration going
and had one of the most successful patents of that era. And you may still, and I don't know if
the college is still getting some money. And of course, Jim getting some money. This is the time release.
Time release, yes, right. Yeah, Jim had, he had, he developed industrial contacts,
and he probably had one of the biggest graduate programs. He believed he's completely retired
on the coast now. And they no longer have a home here in Corvalle. I love Lee and Gerwick. Oh, yes, yes.
He and I actually co-taught in the Biochemistry course, but Bill developed a fabulous natural
products. And was eventually hired away by the University of California, San Diego,
but he had a large program, a very large program. He took a sabbatical in 1972 of Carl's
Rassy. Yes, only about that. Well, I want to take a sabbatical, people do. And so we arranged
for the house to be rented by, I think, a couple that was on sabbatical from somewhere else. And
went down state, rented a house by the University, over Polish couple who had not been back
to Poland since the second World War. And I think family there. Anyway, so I worked in Carl's Rassy's
lab. He's quite an individual. And of course, the father's birth control pale, so on.
And got four papers out. It was a natural products lab, because without we're going to get
really secret going. And we had various ideas. And somehow we never could happen to that well
into the Sea Grant money here. But we thought we could get a marine natural products thing going.
And never did work out. But yeah, it was a good year. Did you get to know him very well?
You, he's one of these people that has a fantastic memory. So he got to know you more than
you got to know him. I mean, I was working on one of the papers. And I said, I've been, I've been,
I've been the camera abstracts. I'm not finding this reference. He got up and went over to his cardfile,
pulled out something from Donas, I hold that paper, but it says here. And he didn't do it in a way
that I felt like shrink in the floor. And I, I don't know how I missed this. Well, I always said,
there, you didn't have computerized search in a camera abstracts in those days. It was all done manually
with big thick volumes and fine print. But anyway, he came up here once he retired as a chemist
and has written three or four novels and some plays sort of a Renaissance man I'd have to say.
And he came up, I can't remember who brought him up. But I went over and during the break,
I reintroduced myself. He seemed to remember who I was. He was friends with Linus Pauling who's also
in the Stanford area at the time. Yeah. And I can't remember if I did go over here when Pauling's
lectures are not. Pauling came back to campus a few times too. You know, it was you.
Yes. Oh yeah. And the only time I heard him on campus that I'm aware of, I can't remember if I
went to any of the peace lectures later on, then after Magnus wife. But there was that one time when
the Afro-American football players walked off the campus because of the beard incident with
our in Mustaches and with D Andrews, the football coach. And Pauling was to
speak at Gil Call of Sam and the students came in and Jensen was president. It was of
it was an awkward situation. And I think Jensen felt very hurt by it because I think basically
it was a very fair man. But you're dealing with a powerful football coach who had powerful alumni
behind him. So it was an awkward situation. And I'm probably when he had to give us talk.
You mentioned Dean of all, he was Dean for 22 years. The longest serving Dean of his generation
in pharmacy apparently. It sounds like there were at least a couple of changes that he
invoked. And one of you mentioned a little bit was that emphasis on increased experience in patient care.
But that was going on during the, I would say that that was a trend in pharmacy education all
across the United States. I mean, he was going to make sure we stayed current.
As part of that, the curriculum added clinical components, including can actually be turned out
awesome. I'll tell you why. Act 2. Yeah. So we were talking about changes in the curriculum and
the focus on clinical components, including communication skills. Yeah, the history of
communication has been a very interesting one. For a long time, the pre
pharmacy curriculum had some type of speech requirement. And the question was always what is the appropriate
type of speech requirement? Is it it? So I think the word is expository speech where you get
up and give you three minutes speech or your five minutes speech, which is not what pharmacists do.
They talk one in one like you and I are talking to each other. And so what you want is,
they're there apparently. It was a speech course that supposedly you was more
how to interact one on one rather than with an audience. I'm not sure if there's still a speech
requirement in the pre pharmacy curriculum or not. It wasn't there when I was an undergraduate.
I can tell you that. I had an high school. But what happened was, was mandatory
counseling. In fact, I was on the board of pharmacy when the mandatory cost of their
requirement went in. And it was happening across the United States. Part of it was patient,
better patient care. Part of it was, get the pharmacists out there talking with the patient,
rather than hiding behind the counter and having some sales clerk hand on that all. So,
one of our, I get to call it, in fact, in my recent director of student health, so it was pharmacy
billed voice. And actually pioneered the technique for how to console a patient. And there's a
little card. And there's three questions on it. I can't remember all of them. Now, they went.
But basically, it was, what did your physician tell you about this medicine? So, your first of
all, rather than get through this lecture and I'm trying to find out what the patients understand.
So, you're not talking down to them. And that's also a good way to do an air checking
in the last minute, because if you're handing them an antibiotic and the patient says,
it's for my high blood pressure, you know, just hang on a moment. We're going to check this out.
But okay, we'll see what's the correct prescription.
Another question might be, what did, and any, could elaborate on the response? Or, yes, I see,
you have a good understanding. What did the physician explain to you on how to take it?
And you find out, do they realize they are to take it? Four meals, or two hours after a meal.
And I can't remember the third one, whether you have any other questions, you want to ask me,
or did the physician explain any of the pertinent side effects? And there you're trying to,
you're not trying to scare the patient, or they'll never take it. But you might also, or if you
do get a certain type of sensation, you need to either call your physician or call us,
rather than simply go up and give them a spiel. So, you're trying to teach that type of
communication on a one-to-one basis. Most deformities are not even set up forward, so you're trying to
have some place in a corner where nobody else can hear the conversation, but
to be an out noise to the store is, Fred Meyer, the product can't hear it because of all the noise,
right as I think you can hear the conversation. I have a silly question, but probably when
you've been asked before, how do pharmacists interpret the handwriting of doctors unless the
scripts that they receive? A lot of it is practice, a lot of it is now electronic transmission,
and one of the most important things is, fallen and find out what it is that was written.
So, there isn't any secret code in other words? No, no. And they're not supposed to write in
Latin anymore in fact, yet I don't know the Latin. It's kind of moving to your career.
I will, one of the, one of the resolutions that we find I got through the National Social
Board's Affirmacy was the test to spoke in English. Not written English, they're supposed
to do that also. spoke in English, and I was very interesting to see the opposition. And of course,
there was all this about a political correctness, but you had to explain that the communication
media is, you could have a resident at a medical center who is from one country in Asia,
talking to a pharmacist who is from India, and the only thing they've got in common is the English
language. Not saying the Asia one may be that is good and English is the Indian one, but the point
is airline pilots and the control towers use English. So, now if a person of pharmacist is dual
language, so they can talk in another language and explain the directions or hand the person
information sheet in the native language, some of the computer programs will do that. Great,
that's excellent, but still got to, still got to be able to speak it. I want to ask you about
you serving an National Science Foundation panel for instructional scientific equipment.
I did, you're right, we're going to have that held down, I think Los Angeles,
I think we all went down there. It was for undergraduate research, and it was a very interesting
panel's one time I did, and I'm not quite sure how my name got in there. God, I never got funded by it.
I'm not sure if I replied, but what was fascinating was you had good solid liberal art schools,
the Lewis and Clark, and this day to Lewis and Clarks, the reads, the Willamets, for example,
applying for, they wanted a new NMR, a new updated infrared species,
putometer for their lab, they would be used and they outlined the courses that would be used in,
and also how it works for undergraduate research projects. And we, oh, and they would also
be able to show how they would be able to support the instrument that they had the technicians
available to keep it going or experience faculty, and you'd fund those. Then you would get
a little small liberal arts college that maybe had one chemist, two if they were lucky,
who wanted this fancy piece of equipment, and you'd say, how are they going to maintain it?
Do you understand how it works? Where is the course that's going to be used in?
We wouldn't fund it. Are you got the application from the chemistry department at the
University of California or the University of Wisconsin and Madison, who just had to have the new
hot, hot, hot, hot NMR, and they were going to let the integrators walk by and say,
no, we didn't fund that either. So we basically funded
liberal arts program. Well, I didn't have to be, I'm sorry, I don't want to imply,
I had to be a private liberal arts school, a school like Western probably would not have any
problem either. They had to have a substantial, we were doing the chemistry area now, please,
keep that in mind. Speaking of the discipline, they had to have a core of faculty.
A one thing that really helped them was we did they have a program that met the undergraduate
standards of the American Chemical Society, which means they had to have, and that had basically
faculty in each of the disciplines, organic, physical, and political.
It's a seemingly important point in the modern history of the College of Pharmacy
came in 1988 when the satellite campus was formed in OHSU. That is still a dynamic situation.
The Oregon State, like some of the other pharmacy schools of history, historical,
are not out in a campus where there is a medical center.
And then the big debate is does the school move to where the medical center is or is the school
state where it is and try to do the satellite campus? And of course we did the latter.
Part of it is how would you move our whole research emphasis and productivity? We are very
productive. If you take a look at the amount of grant money, this pharmacy school is now a bringing in.
Where would, how would it be situated? Where would be the, the supporting infrastructure? I mean,
there's quite a dynamic support all across campus. There's the mass spec centers. There's the
NMR centers and so forth. So there's, there's a real big synergism on a campus like this.
And so how would that be handled in a Portland area? Because there's not a major,
excuse me, Portland State, but there's not a major research university. Their Portland State
is got some real strong areas, don't please don't misunderstand me. And OHSU is a medical center.
They're not teaching the basic science courses that would feed into a medical center.
The students all come in for some more else. So that's one thing.
So initially it was to get the clinical program established up there for the fourth year
and try to get rotations. And that took a lot of missionary work. You might say
to get the medical center to accept. It seems to be working very well now. It really is. And of course,
there's both the medical center OHSU and there is the VA. And there's the other big hospitals,
legacy, Providence, Kaiser. There is, I'm trying to think of basic pharmaceutical
sciences and I have the impression that one emphasizes only an impression that there is some
pharmaceuticals now up in Portland as opposed to just the clinical.
Well another important moment came 11 years later when OHSU decided to log it off for the
bachelor's degree in pharmacy and focus solid on the farm D. Oh yes, that's got a very interesting
history. The question was, was money for one thing to finance because you need an additional
faculty, particularly in the clinical area. And you had to pay going wages because they could all
work in the private sector. So the question came up and I remember Dick talking about Dick
Ophon, talking about it was, do we start a small farm D program and just kind of shoehorn it in?
And there was some type of educational coordinating committee that was they had to approve new programs
to eliminate duplication. I think it's passed by the way so I know. In the chair of that committee
made the comment, he says, no, you wait until we can have a good program. We want excellent
program. The other thing they did that at the state level was saying you can't have a doctor
a professional doctor program unless the students have a bachelor's degree. And there are these
pharmacy schools, unfortunately, in my opinion, who a student would go through and get a doctor
pharmacy degree and not have any bachelor's degree. Well, can you imagine a medical physician
not having a bachelor's degree as far as I know as dentists do? I think all the lawyers now have
bachelor's degree before they get their doctor, jurors, prudence. And so we worked out essentially
seven year program, three year pre-farmacy. We made arrangements with general science that they
would accept courses in the first professional year, maybe some of the second towards the
general science degree. So if they don't have a bachelor's degree, they will by the end of their
second professional year and they have to before they take their last two years. Now it turns out
I believe over 90 percent are coming with bachelor's degrees now. But we were one of the first schools
to require this bachelor's degree requirement. I think Ohio State was coming to the other
always you, ironically, or coincidentally, or whatever I think is in it. I believe there was a
California San Francisco as always, but I should say we're one of the first. I think they always
they're one of the pioneers for the farm deep program and I think they always required a bachelor's degree.
I think they always did and that may have been true of USC also. My understanding is
a large number of the state farmers at schools, the well-established state universities
are now, I've got so much in their pre-farmacy that essentially there's a bachelor's degree requirement.
I don't know about specific, for example, if a person didn't walk in,
obviously, three and four years or year later, actually it had a year around curriculum three and a
half years, walk out with a farm due without a bachelor's degree. I don't know, frankly.
Well, it sounds like this shift of the farm be led to an even closer tie-out of USC, you know,
yes, you agree between the two universities. Because it requires a lot more clinical faculty,
it requires more clerkships, and more making more rounds than that. Yes, yes. There's no there's no
question about it. I want to talk a little bit more about your career. You mentioned your time
on a Oregon Board of Pharmacy. One of the interesting things that you were involved with,
there was assisting with the interpreting and implementation of the playing for a
assisted suicide law. Yes. That was a fascinating experience. Here was a situation.
You had the potentiality of a pharmacist who was opposed to it,
receiving a prescription, and not realizing why they were dispensing it. In fact, they
under the patient constant, they make a lot and give up a bunch of goofy advice, and may not even
realize what was happening, and then you had the situation under the hood. Well, wait a minute,
I'm not going to dispense this and pull it back. So, there were various scenarios. The sponsors
of the physician's system suicide may know if, and some buts about it, there was to be nothing
hidden from the pharmacist, nurses, anybody. It could be an open process, anybody who did not want
to participate, and they actually had networks of physicians and pharmacists, and there's so
forth, who were positive, and they could always put a family in touch, get them into the system.
So, we went back and forth with the board of medical examiners. No, no, scratch that.
We went back and forth with the Oregon Medical Association. It turned out that we've seen
that pretty well have the support of the physicians, including the officers, but there was a lobbyist
who has taken his cue from the American Medical Association, and if a physician doesn't want
to tell the pharmacist anything, that's it. God has spoken. And so, we finally wrote a rule
that said, physicians had to tell the pharmacists. Well, all of a sudden you had the order of
pharmacy, right, and they were all covering the pharmacists. The board of medical examiners were
not upset, because they couldn't get it. They were being shoved, not pushed, not to. And we now
had our rule, and the physician's Oregon Medical Association, their lobbyists, didn't like it at
all. So, of course, for this time I believe Dr. Kitsopper was governor, and so we, in the meantime,
we were trying to get through a clarity drug treatment through, which we had a train general says
we had the authority to do, but the drug industry didn't like it. And this is where pharmacists
can be involved in working out the treatment modalities and the doses so forth. So, we,
another board member and I were called into the governor's health advisor office. And
basically, what the governor did, he told the medical board, you take that board of pharmacy rule
and you rewrite it with your name on it, instead of their name, and you push it through.
Which they did, if that there was a draft and we, we approved it. That was fine. We didn't,
we didn't care. All we wanted was the pharmacists, and all that these prescriptions were coming through.
And so we told the health advisor, that's fine with us. And then he says, so what now,
is it you're trying to do, and we mentioned Clavion Drug Therapy, and this fellow had
was a former EMT or something on the ambulance. That's how he knew kids' hopper. They were
fishing buddies and so then Oregon. And he looked at his, well, is that like when I'm on the ambulance,
I can put start the IV and for a person in cardiac arrest and said, yes, he says, oh, okay,
you got it. I'll tell the law that it's from the OMA that you, it's going to go through. So,
we got what we wanted, and the physicians got, well, if you know, they got what they wanted, but
at least they had face saving on it. So, yeah, that's the story. We're all happy campers now.
We mentioned to you that you served on the foreign pharmacy graduate equivalence examination committee.
Yeah, that's the exam committee with the National Association Board's Affirmacy.
What did that entail? Oh, you had a significant number of graduates of foreign pharmacy schools
that wanted to immigrate to the United States in practice pharmacy. And we had, no, there is no
equivalent of a basic pharmaceutical, a basic medical exam, basic medical science exam. There's
something that medical schools have after a couple of years, I guess everybody takes this test
before they go out in the clinic. I'm not really, I'm really not quite sure how it works,
but there's, there apparently is some type of standard test. There's nothing like that with pharmacy.
So, this is the closest thing to it. If a, and there's other requirements for the graduate,
they've had to have so many years in a pharmacy school that has to meet certain curricular standards
and so on. And there is a test of spoken English by the way, they have to pass.
And of course, the test of English or the foreign language, they have to pass that also.
So, basically, there's a, there's a bank of questions that we work on. I have to be in the
medicinal chemistry area. That's supposed to be equivalent to what, if they can pass it,
then they have at least the minimum standards of graduating in the Dietactic Course Work
in a pharmacy school. Now, they still have to do their interning and that sort of thing.
So, I was in the medicinal chemistry. We meet twice a year. We would come up with questions
just like SATs and these questions that are on there that are going to count and there's
questions that are being tested to see if they're discriminating or they're too difficult or they're too
easy. And so we would be working on new questions plus trying to fix the questions that didn't
test right. And one of the things I did was, in the pine, as they developed this exam,
the chemistry portion, some of the chemical structures were pretty bad. They were bad. So, I
says, well, I've got a, I've got a chemical draw program, which was sort of the standard. And so,
I worked out a deal with them. I didn't get paid, but I re-drew hundreds and hundreds of structures
using the same program. Something I'll see you worked on that is interesting to me and my
background with one is probably he developed them all for general anesthesia and I understand that
that's something you study to the controversy over general anesthesia. Well, that's one of the
contracts with the army. And we were trying to see if there was a receptor for it. I think
there is because they, they've got optically active, sterile chemical, such as the left and right
and the molecules. One is active, the other is not. So, there must be some type of receptor,
but that never led to anything. Do I understand correctly? There still is no accepted theory of
why, you know, anesthesia. I think there is some theories for it, but I'm not, there's some about
nerve conduction where it's going depolarization or I think there is some of that now,
because they can visualize the brain so much differently nowadays with the various types of scans,
the pet scanners and all that, but they can get some idea where which neurons are firing,
which part of the brain's are reacting in certain ways. So, I think, I think they're closer.
We retired in 2003 after 37 years in the College of Pharmacy. We saw a lot of change when we
could reflect on the changes in the College of the course of that time. Well, I mean, we've been talking
about them, but basically it started out to be a traditional batch of five-year batch of degree
program, but there's no chemistry, pharmaceutical analysis, formulation for basic pharmaceuticals,
what they call physical pharmacy, dosing, standard, classic pharmacology, and they were still
teaching pharmacy management if you're going to have your own drug store. So, I think there was
some accounting in there, and as it became more and more obvious that pharmacists were going to
be employees, you saw the management evolve into pharmacy socially economics, so you started,
they started to be the discussion of health care delivery, which population groups can get it,
and why, which ones cannot get it, and why not. Various types of insurance models out there,
then, as I said, the labs disappeared as far as the pharmaceutical sciences went,
there is still, I think they still do a little bit of compounding, some basic compounding,
but I think that's about it, and I'm not even sure, it's a small lab, and they got some sterile
hoods, and I think that's about all they're doing. I think I may be wrong on that too,
they'd have to ask somebody, like the associate dean or somebody to ask them.
Big emphasis on patient care, big emphasis on the clinical pharmacy aspect, which is
person has a certain disease, or a couple diseases, and this drug causes this side effect,
and this drug and our person shows up, and they're taking six or eight, I'm not exaggerating,
six or eight different drugs, and can I be whittled down to three or four, because they take a drug
to get a side effect, to get a drug to treat the side effect, and so on, gets messy.
Of course, with the area diabetes, just use as an example, not used to be basically insulin,
and a couple oral medications, well, there's several oral, and there's a whole bunch of other
drugs that have been discovered that affect the pancreas effect, the alpha cells for the
beta cells, and now there's even looking at the auto-eminology aspect of it, all on the clinical side.
I know that one of the pursuits that you've followed retirement is your volunteer Medicare resource.
Yeah, in this day it's called Shiba Senior Health Benefit Assistance Program,
who's that notebook is sitting over there on your side you there.
Nationally, it's ship Senior Health Insurance Assistance Program with the A having been dropped.
Until very recently, we were part of Center for Medicare and Medicaid Services. I'd have to
go to the computer and find out who the new federal agency is we're on. We are moving under,
I don't guess the move is not complete yet, and I'm not sure politically what the heck was going on,
and we got moved. But I started back in 2005 when the Part D drug programs began,
a person who was the coordinator was looking for volunteers desperately because they needed people to
put the drugs into the what was called Medicare.gov plan finder and find out what Part D plan would
work for them in every tire from pharmacy. So I've been bad at it ever since. I was Shiba
Light for a couple years and then full. I'm not, I think I've seen your one and been county. Now, I believe.
Anyway, we are, of course, go through training. We have to be re-certified every year.
We go through a background check which includes finger printing. Obviously, we have signed
all the confidentiality agreements. We log every contact to go into a obviously secure database
and our password changes every two months. I also, in one of the instructors, we call it new
to Medicare or ABCD, some Medicare Part A, Part B, Part C, Part D. And that's a two hour free
course. Most of them are taught over here at the Benton Center because they're the parking and they're
the classroom with computer facilities. And I'm currently on phone duty now. Oh, I should explain.
If you have a Medicare question or you want to talk to a counselor, there's two ways of doing it.
One is to call the toll-free numbers sale on which you can get off of the web, put the board
and you can achieve it and then you can take it right there. And you punch in your zip code
and it automatically has referred them to Albany. Our sponsor here is RSVP, retired senior volunteer
program and the sponsors for the different Shiba slash ships. Very important, it's not no
a county. The Department of Health, I guess, is their sponsor. And I can't tell you who the sponsors
are in other counties. It's little bit and Lincoln are together. But anyway, you'll go into the RSVP office
at the Council of Government's Office on Queens after you're over there in Albany. And then an email
to go out to the appropriate county with referral. And I'm on phone duty. And the main reason for that
is, is I can't verify. May I mention what you came in? My wife is on foster home and she's
actually under hospice. So I go up three times a day and feed her. Excuse me. And I can't get up to
the senior center. So I get the referrals and so forth. Which is a kind of interesting, I can actually
enjoy it almost better than, I don't mean anti-face to face, but you can, you can, you can get quite
a bit of information over the phone. Yeah. And we have, we have Google Calendar to make appointments,
I can even make an appointment form. It's just a seemingly complicated set of to be dealing with
one of the things we said mentioned in our classes and we'll tell clients when they almost are
feeling sheepish. When you, we worked and you had employer health insurance,
you took the employer plan. That was it. I mean, you might have had a choice to an
high deductible, but basically that was it folks. And they may or may not have had dependency coverage.
Okay, now you're reaching 65. What are you going to do? Are you going to keep working? Or is your
company your employer says fine? If then are you going to draw social security or not?
And a lot of people think, well, if I don't draw social security, I don't go into Medicare.
And no, wrong. At age 65, you have got to enroll in Medicare or you're going to get penalized.
And the penalties can be significant, by the way.
Unless you happen to be an employer group health plan of 20 or more employees.
At which case, you can delay it. So Medicare has been described as yes, no one with the following
exceptions. But it is universal health care single payer for the over 65 and over and for disabled.
It interfaces with private insurance to pick up deductibles and co-insurance.
And this is where a lot of people then should I go with a Medicare supplement? No, it's a
Medicare or should I go with an advantage plan? And if I decide to go with an advantage plan,
which one should I go with? If I decide to go with a Medicare, which one should I go with?
So there are these various. And then there's the fall open enrollment period where people can change plans.
And now with their fertile care act, the Medicare crowd also start making appointments,
because they see all this fall boost in a fertile care act. They want no houses affect them.
It doesn't. Well, it does, but there's nothing that can do about it.
Well, the effect is basically beneficial. They don't at whole slow and disappearing in the party.
So there's clearly a need for people like you to help people navigate.
Oh, it keeps us mentally alert, morally straight.
Well, let's just take a couple more questions for you, that the new building in Portland just opened up.
And I haven't seen it, but they say it's very nice that the other tower,
then it's beautiful view of the river. They could even watch a barge is being launched, you know,
but I, I had not seen the new one up other than drive by it.
So it strikes me as being another important chapter, I guess in the history of pharmacy.
I think they work very, they've been the current dean and the previous dean.
Work very hard to make sure we had the floor space and the labs and so forth to be a fully
not move us there, but to make sure that the faculty there had the resources in our to advance.
A number of more hired as clinical assistant, clinical associate professors, that's a non-tenure
track type of deal with a revolving, fixed term type of thing, but they're a tenure track faculty up there too.
The last thing I want to ask you about is that the university has changed so much in the last few years
and you've been used to change and grow and it's good to your perspective on where I always use heading right now.
Well, I have the impression that we want to be the strongest university in the state, which I have no problem with.
We are, of course, in every county. I think our relationship with the state is quite good.
The amount of extramural funding that we bring in is phenomenal. It's not just NIH, I mean,
there's Ag, there's Sea Grant, all that type of thing. I think the question that OSU has to
really wrestle with as do any research university is making sure that the undergraduate still has a good
education experience, which at a good research university they can. You have good students and you can
get them involved in the search and out of new knowledge. It can be a fabulous, fabulous experience,
but the faculty have to want to enjoy working with undergraduates, not just their graduate students and
their postdocs and for that young assistant professor, that can be a time telling, that can be a
strain because it's hard to get the funding. I mean, back in the days when the funding was more
plentiful, it probably wasn't, but I mean, they are struggling to bring that money in.
And they're hired now with fairly bent of generous startup packages and they return the
university wants them to produce. You might say, almost pay it back. So it's a rough go and I have to
be very candid and say, would I today start out the same way? I think pharmacy was fine.
And with the clinical pharmacy and so forth, I find that more interesting.
Many more instincts the wrong word, but I don't know if I would like to be on that constant gun
of getting funded and get it renewed. I still think that's my temperament.
I felt very fortunate that Dick O'Walk took me under his wing there and said, why did you?
I think he saw it was going to pull in big bucks. Why did you look at the regulatory?
And I think I was successful there.
Well, Dr. Mark, thank you very much. This has been very educational for me and I appreciate
you giving us this time to share your memories of pharmacy. Well, thank you for coming and
whatever I said, I'll be dying.